- Oh you can come this way.
Is it soft, it looks soft.
- So soft.
- Yeah.
- I could sleep in it.
- I know, I'm not allowed to touch people,
but I'm really want to touch your sweater.
- After we leave, I'll
take the sweater off.
- Thank you.
- I'll leave it here
for a couple of days.
- Thank you,
that's thoughtful.
- You touch,
I'll come back, pick it up.
Sounds great.
- Touch your sweater
sounds so creepy.
Put the lotion in the basket.
- Touch my sweater.
- It's awesome.
Wait, I mentioned The Mindy Project,
so is it true that you used to
sneak into her dressing room?
'Cause there's a word for that.
- Yup, yeah, I did.
You know, Mindy, I always
said, lock your doors,
when you're around me, lock your doors.
And a couple times she forgot that so
there were a few times
where I would sneak in
and I would put on her bra.
- Oh my God, please tell
me you took pictures.
- I took pictures of it.
- Great.
- And then you text her.
- 'Cause if you put on her bra
and you don't take pictures
of it, that's really creepy.
Then we go, right there.
There you can see.
- Look at you, you're so free.
- I know, I've never felt more.
- This is how we know you're not a woman,
you look happy in a bra.
(laughing)
- That is true.
I don't know why you guys are
complaining, it felt great.
- That face is what happens
when you release them.
(laughing)
It's like, that's what happens there,
but I love that you sneak into
her room and take pictures.
- Can we just keep that
background up the whole time?
- Just the whole time.
- Is that okay?
- It's so great.